honestly still the whiskey is better
than all of this all of it today we're
trying out a bunch of chasers for
whiskey which we are fans of yeah fans
of whiskey not fans of chasers typically
I'm only having a chaser if I'm having a
vodka shot real women don't need chasers
that's right
I hate pickles and everything about them
oh wait sorry oh what a chase sorry
that is good it immediate aches why the
taste of whatever you were drinking
incredibly unpleasant isn't that great
switch off that sounds scary
it's not like ginger let's do it another
way into it I don't hate it a decent
chaser if one needs one
you can't chase liquor with a candy I do
that all the time I think that's just
eating candy while you drink you know I
think you're right
I would give this chaser a 5 out of 10
because I feel like it's more novelty
than actual negate though whiskey flavor
but what even is it's not like a fish
caught laughs right
you know I honestly could fish time can
you do it first and then I'll try okay
I'm not gonna eat like oh no no no no I
quite obviously do it I can't watch this
I will throw up
Cheers
you
okay trying really hard not to get the
hiccups hots begin the hiccups just
don't like it
alright it dies it
I feel like chasing whiskey with
whiskeys like the full Alpha and Omega
of this whole experiment turn up Tuesday
hey I don't know which one is this one
okay that was great huh I don't hate it
it does get rid of the regular whiskey
taste and replace it with just a very
fireball taste overall experience weird
you know I don't think I'd ever do it
again but at least now I know the more
you know qnd seem rainbow this nearly
killed me
everything else is great um I mean the
only thing that I would specifically
pick out at the chaser would be pickle
juice and that's only when I feel like
having a drink that tastes like a
McDonald's hamburger I have to do work
today